if you treat this issue that in Genting
carefully then it is ready to accept my
name is parrying Verona mock during half
a century I've been trying to understand
how titanium could collaborate with
biological tissue titanium and bone and
marrow unite so the titanium functions
as an anchor for an incorporated
non-biological component in the human
body force integration can be applied to
teeth in your head but in all parts of
the human skeleton this procedure has
been applied and by many companies all
over the world and now there are a
couple of million patients treated with
very good long-term results quite a few
of these patients who have lost major
part of their face when they've got the
Anchorage they feel that well I am
acceptable I can go out we have a small
project in Brazil where we have a
special hospital where the patient don't
have to take where doctors from all over
travel and participate in the treatment
I have a very special dedication to
bring basic science in biology to
improving the quality of life of human
beings Gothenburg has been a place where
it was possible to have the free
thinking
you